what up space fam goes in here from
anime opera back at it again with
another attack on titan video
and today we're going to discuss the
final villain of attack on titan so make
sure to stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
time videos and want to keep them coming
the best thing you could do is warhammer
smash that like button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
attack on titan playlist where we got
videos about the titan shifters the
ackermans and much more link to that is
in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it before we get into the final villain
discussion
i think it's useful to take a look at
how the perspective of who is the real
villain constantly shifted an attack on
titan
at first the titans seemed like the
villains aaron was bent on destroying
all of them he was young
naive and the difference between good
and evil seems so
obvious humans the good guys are
fighting against those monsters trying
to kill them for no reason
however that view got complicated soon
enough first aaron turned out to be a
titan shifter himself which complicated
the clear distinction between humans and
titans
then we find out that annie reiner and
bertolt are intelligent titan shifters
too
and they actively plotted to destroy the
people within the walls
so people they trusted as comrades
turned out to be the same people who
attacked them
and killed many of their people
including aaron's mother we'll
eventually find out that annie reiner
and bertolt came from outside the walls
however not all threats came from
outside
during the royal government arc the
government itself becomes the enemy of
the survey corps and people like kenny
the ripper and his team
don't hesitate to kill survey corps
members humans are killing humans and
that's a huge shock for our team
because our guys have to get used to the
uncomfortable idea of having to kill
humans rather than just titans
one of if not the craziest paradigm
shifts in attack on titan
took place during the basement reveal
and wow if we thought the lines were
blurred before
they were blown to smithereens after
they discovered the truth about the
outside world
whereas aaron thought the titans were
actually keeping them from being free
it turned out that the titans were
actually sort of protecting them from
the outside world who've used them as
the devils
and would like them to be eradicated and
by protecting them i don't mean the
titans were consciously protecting them
i just mean
they were in the way and would
inconvenience any attempt
to take over parody island by land in
young grisha's view
you could say the nation of marley was
the enemy that was discriminated against
the alien people of the continent
but in marley's view the aldians were
the enemies who supposedly used the
power of the titans to treat them
way worse for way longer in their eyes
the aldians should consider themselves
lucky
that the merciful marlene spared their
lives after everything their ancestors
did
even if they do have to live in
internment zones one of the ways
marlene's
punish aldians who tried to challenge
them and restore the aldean empire is by
taking them to parody island where they
turned them into titans so those
mindless titans who seemed like the
clear bad guys in the beginning of the
series turned out to be
patriots who were actually fighting for
ldn freedom
the monsters that aaron hated and wanted
to kill so bad
were actually victims of marlene cruelty
and they actually wanted similar
things to what aaron aimed for the
freedom of the aldian people
so at this point in the story after we
catch up on what's happening on the
merlion side
reiner the traitor stopped seeming like
as much of a villain in fact as we
discover he went to the island to be a
hero and he as a
child was brainwashed to believe that he
was doing the right thing
and making his mother proud in the
process as i mentioned he was a kid and
after everything he did he developed a
lot of mental problems
and even started wishing to die this
doesn't seem like a pure evil villain to
me
and even an older aaron tells reiner
that he had no choice
after all his mission was to save the
world reiner and aaron have a very
interesting conversation before the
latter turns into a titan and attacks
willie tiber you can see how much aaron
has matured he no longer views the world
in terms of bad guys and good guys just
in terms of people doing what they have
to do
as he says and i quote willie tiber is
exactly right
i'm the bad guy i might just destroy the
world but you look like the bad guys to
me
too end quote he explains that he
thought everyone beyond the sea
were an enemy at first but after coming
there realized that inside the walls and
out they're all the same so he tells
reiner to forget about aaron's old
naive stated mission to see reiner and
his people have the most
excruciating death possible for what
they did he's no longer after revenge
but still he's looking out for the
future of parody island and its
inhabitants
aaron says that reiner was an ignorant
child and all of that brainwashing was
beaten into him by ignorant adults
so if we take this conversation into
account it seems like aaron is signaling
out
ignorance as the true enemy of humanity
that leads one side to demonize another
and thus justify doing horrible things
to them
aaron also stated earlier as i mentioned
that he is the bad guy now
and a lot of people have made the
argument that aaron is the bad guy of
the final season
and that he's become the villain of the
story and if we do agree that aaron's
the final villain of the story then you
gotta apply the batman quote
you either die a hero or you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
end quote the fascinating thing is that
the world considers aaron to be the
worst
villain ever and yet we saw his history
and how he became what he did
because of his environment and history
as he mentioned to reiner
because he was born into this world and
on the island he decided
to do what he could to save it and his
people even if that meant making an
enemy of the entire world
and you'd have good reason to argue that
aaron our protagonist is the final
villain of attack on titan he easily
killed more people than anyone else in
the entire series
he almost wiped out everyone on earth
using the rumbling
including many innocent civilians and
even children what's more
if we compare his actions to rhinos when
he attacked the island aaron is an adult
and didn't seem to be brainwashed when
he decided to do what he did
furthermore practically everyone else
alive fought against him they all united
in an attempt to stop
aaron jaeger the devil of the earth
including the marlians warriors the
survey corps members and even mikasan
armin
however is aaron pure evil absolutely
not
and that's one of the main points of
attack on titan no one is just good or
just bad
even the marlene gross who i think is
one of the most hateable characters in
the story loves his children and acts
with cruelty
only to aldians is he a piece of crap
totally he's a monster
he unleashed dogs on grisha's young
sister and committed countless other
heinous acts against aldians without
showing any remorse but even this guy
who's the closest thing to a caricature
of a bad guy
is not a bad guy to many people like his
children and nation aaron at least
doesn't enjoy
causing suffering but he does feel in my
opinion like this
is the only option he has to save armin
mikasa and the rest of his people
whether his plan is to take on all the
hatred of the world in order to show the
remaining world that the other eldians
who helped stop him
are not the bad guys or whether he's
acting because it's the only way to
finally stop
a time loop i'll link that theory video
in the description
either way i think we all know that
aaron's motives
aren't pure evil despite how horrible
his actions are
as he explained to reiner he's not doing
this for revenge he recognizes that all
humans are the same
he just feels like he has no other
choice and i hope the final chapter
gives us even more insight into exactly
why he feels this way
so you could totally argue that aaron is
the final villain of attack on titan if
you recognize that that doesn't mean
he's 100
bad it just means that he's doing things
so horrible that practically
everyone is united in their will to stop
him even his best friends
another option for the final villain of
attack on titan is amir fritz
the first and strongest titan she's the
one that gave aaron the power to do this
however again this isn't a very
satisfying view since as
aaron said she's not a god or a devil
just a human she's been slaving away in
the world of paths
and obeying the orders of the royal
family for two thousand years
in her life she was a poor girl that was
chased down and almost killed for
letting a pig go free
when aaron was the first to recognize
her humanity in forever
and offered her a way out of an eternity
of servitude you can begin to see why
she agreed to help him and if you watch
my time loop theory video
you'll get even more insight into her
possible motives and actions
then there's the shiny centipede
creature that attached to a mirror
2 000 years ago and started this whole
titan nightmare what we knew about this
creature was very little for the longest
time
emir entered into a giant tree and
somehow fell into an underground
water source where we saw this
spine-like creature attached to her
spine
and this led to the first ever titan
transformation however the more the
story went on from here the more reasons
we got to believe that this creature
wasn't just some magic tool that humans
use
it has its own will and goals recently
in chapter 137 this creature got
foregrounded the chapter starts with the
following quote
long long ago when nothing but mere
matter existed in this world
as countless masses of some unknown
things appear disappeared and appeared
again
one of them eventually survived we now
know it as
life end quote as we're being told this
we see a centipede-like creature
just like the one that attached to a
mirror from long ago underwater and i
didn't notice this before but there
appeared to be at least two other
specimens of the species
in this panel what's being suggested
here is that this is one of the oldest
things
on earth and as zeke mentions it adapted
and did what it needed to do
in order to survive and multiply and one
of those things was attaching to a
mirror this is a possible theory that i
mentioned before
where this creature which comes from
nature was manipulating aaron and amir
in order to destroy the humans because
they are a threat to the natural world
now that we know more it seems like the
creature may be lending its power to
humans
so they can carry out their plans while
also ensuring its own survival and
multiplication
through them as well think about it all
subjects of emir
are connected to the coordinate aka to
this centipede-like creature
so it's not far-fetched to assume that
all subjects of emir are in a way the
children of this creature which is what
gives them the ability to turn into
titans too
for the first time in chapter 137 the
centipede creature was
actually attacked like an enemy when it
got separated from aaron
reiner tackled it and now the battle
with it has been going on
although after the latest chapter
chapter 138 it is possible
it won't be able to survive without a
living founder body
but it also may be able to since it was
a separate being when it attached to a
mirror in the first place
on its own this creature can release gas
that will turn subjects of emir into
titans
we saw falco scream when everyone began
to turn
which could suggest that it can briefly
take control of subjects of emir to an
extent
although to what extent is not yet clear
since it hasn't stopped reiner and the
others from attacking it
it also appears to be able to control
the titans it creates and turns them
loose on reiner
right now this creature seems to be the
main villain that everyone is trying to
stop
and although we will hopefully learn
more about it in the next
chapter for now it just seems to be a
living thing
doing whatever it can to keep on living
as it's been doing so this brings us to
zeke who at one point saw life
itself and the need to survive at all
costs and multiply your genes
as the villain for him life was an evil
and the solution was to wipe out the
alden race from existence
however he also eventually came around
right before his death and realized that
life is worth it
when you focus on the good moments like
when he played catch
with his father figure tom ultimately as
you may well have noticed by now
there are many potential final villains
in this series and
who or what your final villain is
largely depends on your perspective we
should get more
answers in the last chapter but at the
end of the day
i seriously doubt isayama will leave us
with one clear villain
if there had to be a villain then as
aaron suggested before
it's ignorance it's people's fear of
others and the unknown that fear leads
them to discrimination and violence and
begins a cycle of hatred and fighting
that can potentially go on forever
if all people treated others the way
they wanted to be treated which is the
golden rule in like every religion
then people would never resort to
violence however
fear self-interest and greed creates
conflict and once the conflict gets
going
it's almost impossible to put a stop to
it case in point
aaron felt like he had to practically
destroy the entire world to finally stop
the cycle of hatred
i'm not one of those people who believe
that anime is for pure escapism
and attack on titan in particular is
definitely not the kind of anime that
lends itself to pure escapism since
there are so many clear references to
world war
ii and other real world issues in it i
think works like attack on titan invite
us to question and maybe adjust the way
we view
and live in the real world i obviously
don't think war
is going to disappear overnight because
of the story and i don't even know if
having a world with
no conflict is possible however what
great works of fiction like attack on
titan do is
show us where acting with ignorance and
a self-centered world view can lead us
and knowing that there's the hope that
will be at least a little more
understanding of others and perhaps make
a greater effort to consider
and understand their points of view
perhaps people will be a bit slower to
label other people as enemies and a bit
quicker to see all people as
fellow human beings with equally complex
lives
such small shifts in individuals can
have ripple effects on the whole world
and help create a better future
even if a perfect one is impossible or
at least i'd like to believe that
stories have that kind of power
anyways that is it for this video i hope
you enjoyed it
let me know your thoughts on these
so-called villains and who or what would
you single out as the final villain of
attack on titan
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do is warhammer smash
that like button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next video to drop feel free to check
out my growing attack on titan playlist
where i got videos about the titan
shifters
the ackermans and much more link to that
is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord wigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grata acquire respect pate heffa liam
thompson
al-jatal dr cortman dustin scarlett
the toasted chi bang emperor otaku
spidey life tinel
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and yuno
and are pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazowski cricket xp
retuain de aura very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia the red haired raven ted note 10
i sparky 65 fat boy games deadly saint
and soul rise slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support mormon by going
over to patreon.com
animeoutpro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link to that is in the
description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content now if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you